[Music]
Netflix is in the news because ever
since Netflix raised their fees I mean
really raise them customers have been
leaving in droves customers are upset
so yesterday Netflix CEO Reed Hastings
released a video to apologize for the
rate hikes customers still really mad
the apology didn't work that's why today
Hastings released another video with his
latest plan to win you back
hello I'm Reed Hastings president and
CEO of Netflix our recent pricing change
from $9.99 a month for combined
streaming and DVD services to $7.99 each
per service I admit was not our most
popular move but we want to win you back
and that's why you should consider our
new free service easy play where one of
our representatives will come to your
house to personally open your Netflix
Qwikster envelope then place the DVD in
your DVD player and get a plan do any
dishes you have in your sink meet your
house then if you want watch the movie
with you and answer any questions you
may have about it
second we're offering new cheaper plans
to choose from like The Blind Side plan
where for only forty nine cents per
month we'll send you only copies of the
Sandra Bullock movie The Blind Side
watch The Blind Side send it back we'll
send you back another copy of it once
for only a dollar 49 per month we have
the live star plan where we will
actually send the star of any movie to
your home providing that movie stars
Jason Biggs or Paul Hogan and the train
of DVDs will be easier than ever when
you're finish simply throw the DVD out
of any moving car place it in a bush tie
it to a balloon even flush it down the
toilet
can't do that hand it to any elderly
person put it under your pillow throw it
in the ocean hide it in your local
grocery stores produce section or leave
it on a public bus don't worry we'll get
it but listen we messed up and we're
sorry not sorry enough to lower the
price but still pretty sorry come back
please
[Applause]